hey guys I'm going to do a video on how
to add a theme or any other add-on to
your Firefox Internet Browser
um so go ahead and open up our Fox for
this tutorial and I want to add this
theme into my option so I want to be
able to use this thing for Firefox
so I just hit add to Firefox if if this
one's not compatible with your version
of Firefox you can tell what version you
have by going to tools now going to help
and going to about Firefox to see what
version you have I have
was it 3.0.5
so it'll be grayed out if you cannot uh
add it to your version of Firefox I'll
say this add-on is for older versions
so with the newest version I don't add
to Firefox that's why you have to hit it
says requires you accept the uh user and
license agreement I accept and I
installed
it'll instantly come up with this box
that's how easy it is so only installs
from authors you trust well this is when
I want to install hit the install now
button
first it has to download this one's just
1.8 Megs simple theme it's going to make
it look like Internet Explorer
and usually chains will require you to
restart so I'm gonna hit the restart
Firefox button
take a little my background there
so now
graphox is real
and open it up again
boiler now the theme has not been
applied it's right back at my last
uh website so
tools add-ons
themes
Vista Arrow
and you can use your default theme
or use Vista Aero theme now I'm using
this Arrow theme so fly on the tab
you'll see it looks like it actually
looks a lot like Internet Explorer it's
quite good
looks decent
and that is how you install add-ons
Internet Explorer if you ever want to
uninstall an add-on
um say I don't like the theme hit the
uninstall button
on a stall again and reinstall fire
restart Firefox and that's as easy as it
takes to uninstall a clock's add-on bam
right back into the old Firefox theme
all your old add-ons will remain now
this gun I really like it
so um
yeah leave a few comments subscribe to
my channel
a ton more videos coming guys thanks for
watching peace